Speaker 1: Let's talk a little bit
more about just a wacky first 48
hours of 2024 presidential campaign for
former ambassador to the United Nations,
former South Carolina Governor Nikki Haley.
Really a very bad first couple of days. Day
one of her campaign video surfaced wherein Nikki
Haley defends the Confederate flag and wrongly
claims that states can just choose to secede from
the United States. Day two, which was yesterday.
Nikki Haley holds her first campaign event and
plays the exact same type of identity politics
that Republicans claim to be against. I'm a
woman. I'm a minority. I thought Republicans
told us identity politics is bad or is it only bad
when the left does it? Here, she invokes her own
uniqueness racially to claim the country's not
racist, which is a really popular line among
Republicans. In doing so, not only does she play
identity politics, she kind of seems to prove the
country might be racist. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Joe and Kamala even say America is
racist. Nothing could be further from the
truth. The American people know better.
My immigrant parents know better and take it
from me. The first minority female governor
in history. America is not a racist country.
Speaker 1: You know, I'm not sure. First of all,
overt identity politics, just the exact type
of identity politics that they attack all the
time. Let's put the hypocrisy aside for a second.
Hypocrisy knows no bounds at this point with these
people. I don't know that when you say we elected
the first minority woman governor in 2011, that
it's the strongest evidence that the U.S. at least
wasn't a racist country. It seems like a little
bit late in the game to be able to make that case.
By the time that the country was hundreds of years
old, we finally elected the first minority female
governor, which proves there's no race problem in
the United States or gender problem. No woman
president ever. First woman VP. Not until 2020.
These are not particularly compelling data
points, to be perfectly honest with you.
Nikki Haley continuing to play the same identity
politics that she says is bad when other people
do it. Saying May the best woman win.
Speaker 2: I will simply say this.
May the best woman win you all.
Speaker 1: Pretty clever line. Hi, guys.
The crowd not exactly reflecting and saying,
Wait a second, I thought we were supposed to
be against that type of identity.
Paul. No, the crowd simply cheers.
One other interesting note. She kicked off this
event with a prayer from extremist Pastor John
Hagee. I'm not even going to waste your time
with a clip, but I will briefly mentioned
that John Hagee runs the Cornerstone Church
in San Antonio, Texas. Extremist, lunatic,
long history of saying crazy stuff. He said Hitler
was sent by God to usher in the state of Israel.
He said Hitler was a half breed Jew. He called
the Catholic Church the great whore. He has said
insane things about abortion and 911, all these
crazy things. And Nikki Haley started this off
by saying, I still want to be Pastor Hagee when I.
Speaker 2: Grow up where I start, I've got to give
a shout out to the people who took the podium.
Speaker 1: By the way, plagued
with audio issues the entire event.
Speaker 2: Me, too. Pastor Hagee, I still
say I want to be you when I grow up. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Beautiful and very, very muted clapping
at that moment. Everything about this event was
pathetic, humiliating and hypocritical. But there
was one really funny moment from this event which
I want to actually devote a little bit of time to.